these were some of Grace malanez last
moments the night before her 22nd
birthday captured on CCTV in Auckland in
December last year whilst travelling
around New Zealand here she was waiting
for a date arranged through tinder just
hours later the 27 year old man she met
turned out to be her murderer in court
today at the end of a three week trial
jurors took about five hours to convict
him of her murder CCTV footage from that
night showed grace and a killer on their
date first they went to a burger bar and
then spent several hours drinking
cocktails before going to the man's
hotel room the footage shows them going
into the lift and up to the third floor
this is the last moment grace Mullane
was seen alive in interviews with the
police the 27 year old claimed grace
died accidentally during rough sex I
didn't hit the button and because I was
scared
what did you think it looked bad more
this a dead person in my room I thought
it looked terrible hours of CCTV footage
was shown in court here the man visits a
shop just after 8:00 a.m. the following
day he bought a large suitcase and took
it back to the hotel where he was living
he then went to a general store to buy
cleaning products
two hours later he goes to a car rental
where he rented a small red hatchback
the court was also shown footage of the
27 year-old going on another date with
another woman arranged through tinder at
this point Grace's body was still in his
hotel room during the trial jurors heard
that after the murder the killer
searched online how to dispose of a
corpse he also watched extreme
pornography later that evening he left
his hotel room with two suitcases on a
trolley one of them contained grace
malanez naked body forced into a fetal
position the next morning he buried the
body in woodland just outside Auckland
city centre grace malanez parents were
present for every day of this trial
their pain outside court today was clear
grace was taken away from us in the most
brutal fashion a year ago their lives
have been unfairly been ripped apart
this will be with us for the rest of our
lives grace was a beautiful talented
loving Dora Geiss was a sunshine and she
will be miss forever she did not deserve
to be murdered in such a barbaric by a
year ago grace Mullane came to New
Zealand to explore and enjoy life as a
backpacker today the man who killed her
showed no emotion as the court found him
guilty of murder
in Xiamen rasheed Sky News